المتزوجون حديثًا في
مشاهد الحب من حفل زفاف ماراي
ميسنسوف وإطارات ميرزات عام 2016
، تسميه اليقطين الذي يسميها
قرده ،
إنه يشبه إلى حد كبير الحب من النظرة الأولى
الذي التقى به الزوجان عبر الإنترنت ، ولدت ماراي في
أستراليا وميرزات من الأويغور العرقيين
من منطقة شينجيانغ الصينية
حيث كان يعمل في مطعم والده
بعد زفافهما في شينجيانغ ، قضى
العروسين ثمانية أشهر سعيدة
معًا هناك
حتى منحت أستراليا تأشيرة الزوج ،
ميرزات خطط للهجرة مع مهاري
إلى أستراليا
في أبريل 2017 ولكن قبل يومين
من رحلتهما من
شرطة شينجيانغ الصينية ظهرت  في
منزلهم ، أعطاهم جواز سفرهم
وصادروه في ذلك الوقت ، وهناك في تلك
الليلة احتجزت الشرطة ميرزات ،
تعلم أنك متزوج حديثًا ،
فأنت تستعد لبدء حياتك
معًا
، ثم تنقلب تمامًا
رأسًا على عقب  ثم الشيء التالي الذي
تعرفين أن زوجك
موجود في مركز احتجاز ولا يمكنك
حتى رؤيته لا يمكنك ذلك  ven للتواصل
معه
تقول محرز إن ذلك يمثل بداية
محنة استمرت أربع سنوات
، وتقول إن ميرزاد احتُجز في
معسكرات الاعتقال لشهور في
ثلاث مناسبات منفصلة
بينما لم يواجه أي تهم
رسمية حتى 1 أبريل
عندما تم استدعاء والدي مرزاد إلى
مركز احتجاز وأبلغوا أن ابنهم
قد
أدين بجريمة الانفصال ، وذلك
عندما تلقيت خبرًا
بأنهم حكموا على زوجي بالسجن 25
عامًا و
25 عامًا
، ولم أكن مثل لا ، هذا لا يحدث ، كنت
من هذا النوع  حدث أنهم لا يستطيعون فعل
ذلك ،
وتعتقد ميراي أن زوجها مسجون
هنا في منشأة محصنة
نمت بشكل كبير على مدار السنوات
الثماني الماضية ، وهو واحد من عشرات
المعسكرات الأمنية المشددة
التي تم توسيعها مؤخرًا في
شينجيانغ وفقًا لتحليل أجراه مركز
الأبحاث الأسترالي
تظهر إحصائيات الحكومة الصينية التي جمعتها منظمة هيومن
رايتس ووتش لأول مرة
أن عدد الأشخاص
المحكوم عليهم بالسجن في شينجيانغ
spi  قفز ked بشكل كبير
ست مرات تقريبًا بين عامي 2014
و 2018. يعتقد بعض الخبراء أن الصين
تنقل احتجازها
الجماعي المزعوم للأقليات المسلمة من
معسكرات الاعتقال إلى السجون الرسمية ،
وهي سياسة يزعم المزيد والمزيد من الناس من
شينجيانغ
أنها تمزق عائلاتهم بعيدًا عن نارولا
إليما الأويغور
من  شينجيانغ التي تعيش الآن في
السويد أمضت السنوات الثلاث الماضية في
الضغط من أجل إطلاق سراح ابنة عمها
مايلا ياكوفا ، وهي معلمة لغة الماندرين
وأم لثلاثة أطفال ، احتُجزت لأول مرة
في عام 2018
بتهمة تمويل الإرهاب ، ثم
تلقت نارولا مكالمة الفيديو هذه في فبراير من
والدتها
في شينجيانغ مع  تحديث مدمر عن
ابنة
عمها حكموا عليها لمدة ست سنوات
وستة أشهر. كيف تتعامل عائلتك
مع
هذه الإدانة ، أعتقد أنهم ماتوا
داخل العائلة شاركوا هذه الرسالة من مايلا
المكتوبة في الحجز
والتي تدعي أنها أُجبرت على
التوقيع على اعتراف
ط  ليس لديها القوة لمقاومة مثل هذه
القوة كتبت
أن الحكومة الصينية قد ذهبت  من
إنكار سياسة الاحتجاز الجماعي في البداية
إلى الدفاع الآن عن حملة القمع
بحجة أنها تقاتل التطرف الإسلامي ،
يزعم هذا الفيلم الوثائقي التلفزيوني الذي تم إصداره في أبريل أن
هناك طابورًا خامسًا من
المسؤولين الحكوميين
الذين تآمروا سراً لتحويل شينجيانغ
إلى وطن مستقل
للأويغور ويتهم هذا الرجل  قام أبو بكر
وشقيقه بالدفع لإرسال مراهقين من الأويغور إلى
الخارج
حيث يُزعم أن البعض انضم إلى
الدولة الإسلامية ،
كيف كان رد فعلك عندما رأيت
والدك ،
لا ، لم أستطع حتى التعرف عليه ،
لقد رفضت تصديق أن الرجل كان والدي
ابنة الرجل المتهم؟  ديلسار
أبلاميت ، طالبة جامعية تبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا
تدرس في الخارج في تركيا ، تقول إن
والدها اختفى
منذ أربع سنوات في شينجيانغ حتى
ظهر فجأة
في هذا الفيلم الوثائقي الصيني
،
لم يكن والدي وعمي إرهابيين أو
انفصاليين
لم يكن الفيلم الوثائقي كذلك  يقول ما إذا كان
الأخوان قد اتهموا بارتكاب جريمة
طلبت CNN الحكومة الصينية
أبو  أعلنوا عن وضعهم
ووضع الآخرين في تقريرنا
ودفعنا للحصول
على إجابات حول سبب إلقاء الكثير من الأويغور
في السجن
في أستراليا.
بعد أن
علمت أن زوجها سيقضي
الخمسة وعشرين عامًا القادمة خلف القضبان ،
يجب أن أقاتل من أجله ، يجب
أن أكون قويًا من أجله ، يجب أن أفعل
شيئًا لا يمكنني
الاستمرار في الجلوس وأنت تعلم أن
التزم الصمت حيال
ذلك  أعتقد أنك سترى زوجك
مرة أخرى ،
آمل حقًا لذلك
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل
عدم رؤيته مرة أخرى إيفان واتسون CNN
هونج كونج لذلك نريد أن نؤكد هنا
أن CNN تواصلت مع الحكومة الصينية
للتعليق على هذه القصة التي
لم تستجب لها  أسئلتنا